let's party you're like he's kind of
dead but he's also back for this moment
collapse like a little closer follow sir
C it is in a rhythm it's not in a random
Rhythm okay and I
do hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi
Barbie hi Barbie okay great that s good
now go get him let's just sing all the
way through it and pretend like we're
learning it stupid and crazy so
ridiculous look at you look at you go
that was perfect Timothy and go run no
yes you mess up don't stop and messed up
that's people mess up and I think it's
like more charming and more like the
more real it is those are the things
that will be really special about it so
don't think you're messing anything up I
want you like who you are that's why
you're here and I like all of you so
much and whatever that is going be right
Lucas You better kiss
her and cut that was great